the eyes have it the motion went through
on the nod in parliamentary speak
unopposed not requiring a vote
triggering an inquiry into the
possibility that boris johnson lied to
mps about lockdown parties in downing
street
an amendment aimed at scuppering the
motion was removed on thursday morning
apparently amid government fears of a
large-scale rebellion by its own mps who
didn't wish to be seen as blocking
parliamentary scrutiny ahead of local
elections next month instead some found
it hard to contain their distaste
i have to say i'm sorry that for not
obeying the letter and the spirit and i
think we have heard that the prime
minister did know what the letter was
the prime minister now should be long
gone yeah madam deputy speaker i'll
certainly vote for this motion but
really the prime minister should just
know the gigs are i'm profoundly
disappointed
in what happened at number 10 dining
street
people were badly let down
my constituents feel badly let down
i feel personally badly let down by what
happened
and
there must be consequences that follow
from that
the prime minister on a visit to india
said he had nothing to hide i'm very let
me just say i'm very keen for every
possible form of of uh scrutiny and if
the house comms can do i think whatever
it wants to do but all i would say is i
don't think that uh that should happen
until uh the investigation is completed
and that's my only uh point and i've
said this time and time again let's get
the uh let's let the the investigators
do their stuff
boris johnson has already been fined by
the metropolitan police for attending a
downing street event his own birthday
party in fact in breach of covet 19
lockdown rules parliament's privileges
committee made up of seven cross party
mps will begin its inquiry only after
the police investigation is over it will
look at whether boris johnson
deliberately misled mps lied to them in
other words when he said back in
december that no kovid 19 rules had been
broken remember he maintains that he
believed then he had not broken any
rules
that defense could wear thin if as
expected johnson receives up to three
more fines for other events among more
than a dozen under investigation the
privileges committee would have access
to much of the evidence the police have
relied upon including hundreds of
photographs
he is already the first serving prime
minister to have been sanctioned by the
police for breaking the law while in
office now boris johnson is set to
become the first in recent times to be
investigated for lying to parliament a
finding if it comes that could force his
resignation joe nahul al jazeera
westminster